on this episode it's a good one I like
it actually
that's what this episode is about so
really solid three episodes in a row
killer
[Music]
you
hi
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 2 27 of
the ask gary vee show I gotta tell you
what's a Wednesday three episodes in a
row India get over here
don't be scared I know the table's small
for some weird reason all of a sudden it
was broke it was broken you saw that but
Simon was a good episode a lot of great
feedback from the Simon episode India a
lot of people are excited to see you
again people do you see all the tweets
I'm like wait India still works at beta
people thought I fired I loved it um
well yet you you clearly if you were not
gonna be here anymore
it would be more about you being fired
yeah so uh there's a Tyler am i doing
one tomorrow a scary to be tomorrow yes
no we got a sneak one in because I think
I can go five days this week that'd be
huge all right
fight for it ah yes all things are good
I'm very focus I feel this shows have
been really good this week like from the
quality of the content I don't think
I've been as entertaining but I think
that the answers have been strong
obviously the saltiness oh by the way we
have to do one tomorrow cuz I've been
making my Jets prediction I had a
strategy of not doing predictions this
year it didn't work week one so I'm
gonna give a prediction tomorrow against
Chris sokka's Buffalo Bills India let's
get into the show yo what's some of the
videos you guys are about who do we only
do videos now is that did we agree to do
that actually all right we're gonna do a
lot more videos if you want to get in
the show use the hashtag askgaryvee and
submit more video questions I'm into it
hi Gary this is yella from Belgium first
other one start with thanking you for
putting out all that content I've been
an entrepreneur for over five years now
and I feel like that I am becoming a
better businessman a better entrepreneur
thanks to your content and insight so
thank you for that this is my question
I've been working together with a few
interns for a couple of years now
and they're always around 21 years old
and I feel that they're liking two
important skills the first skill is
critical thinking or self-criticism they
should think about what should i do
first and what next why am i advising
this is what I produced really good
enough and the next the second skill is
taking ownership when all given tasks
are finished do they start thinking
about what the next best step could be
do you have any idea how I as a boss as
a guide can help them develop their
skills Thanks listen I think that um I
think that the answer to your question
is the critique that you are putting on
them you are critiquing them for this
kind of thoughtfulness critical thinking
and then action and taking the
initiative and being on the offense my
answer to you is you need to do the same
with you as a boss and you need to audit
yourself to do that meaning there is no
reason that you should be in a scenario
where you're struggling with 21 year old
interns for a long period of time
because the truth is if you put the time
and effort to really audit them and
really spend time with them and then
decide for you whether you're right or
wrong as the judge in the jury as the
boss that they're good or they're not
good you could speed up this process
very quickly so my answer to you is go
deep and spend more time with them
whether that's virtually or in reality
you know or in real life whether
wherever you wear these interns are
figure out if they're good give them
very detailed feedback at scale
suffocate all the excuses and then make
a decision whether that person should be
in your organization or not for me if I
wanted to know if anybody here should be
in my organization or not it would
literally take me two days like you just
make it the thing you do today today you
should decide if these interns are
capable have the talent and the capacity
to deliver on your expectation
or not have you been clearing them and
and move forward so I think the answer
to your question is in the same way that
you're upset with them that when their
task is done they're not doing the next
thing I'm upset with you which is if you
slept last night
you could have allocated some of those
hours to auditing your interns and
giving them clear feedback and making a
decision if you wanted them here or not
do it buster question for you now I know
what you did at age 12 13 14 15 16
getting involved in wine and selling
sports cards but what would you be doing
if it were 2016 and you were 12 13 14
and 15 and 16 appreciate your answer
appreciate everything you do thanks
Buster Buster Buster honestly what I
would tell you is to give you the answer
that you're looking for which is what
what would I do if what should you be
doing how should you be thinking about
things reverse engineer your strengths
right you like the NBA you should hit up
dunk first of all that haven't put you
on but besides that I think that you
need to figure out what you're good at
and what would you want to do I would
basically be today I'm trying to think
there be so many things I'd be doing
today like I give a lot of that advice I
would have made Bank on snapchat filters
I I think that one guy who did the
Pokemon go consulting I think that was
super smart the having the internet to
buy and sell I'm a salesman buying and
selling uh just buying stuff on you know
in Asia and remarketing in the US I
think I'd be doing pretty much
everything I was doing at scale so
because when I was growing up sports
cards or what people collected I would
just be focused on whatever that version
is now sneakers I'm telling you right
now I would be my stories of Toys R Us
and garage sales would be waking would
be waking up you know at 1:00 in the
morning and standing in line at a at a
soho sneaker store to get that thing
flipping like i could be doing a lot of
that and so you know i think the truth
is buster I be focusing on what I was
strong Adam what I think I'm really good
at is buying and selling I did that with
stuff my whole life now I do it with
people's attention and the end consumers
attention that is my strength
would double down on that you my friend
need to figure out what you're best at
is that making content on social media
is that being a charismatic personality
that I think it was shining through and
that question is that but is that being
a sales person buying selling stuff
connecting with people when you're 16
you have time like Jesus that one you
were bored no one you could do that and
they remembered you're like I'm bored
like you don't have that kind of time
when you grow up and so I would take
advantage of that time because that is
the asset number being bored yeah
Brandon hey Gary my name is Brandon and
I'm social media manager for a digital
magazine app in midtown Manhattan called
Zinio looks a little something like this
my question for you is how do we
leverage content from five thousand-plus
magazines to those jabs at a millennial
customer whose attention is typically
away from magazines thanks so much for
answer you keep answering questions I'll
keep asking that Brandon have a couple
things one your avocado and bassinger I
need to figure out what that means
you're also a Mets fan but I'm in
singing Jets love and I'm very concerned
that you might be one of those rare
people that our Mets and giant fans who
I hate oh so much uh I I didn't fully
get the context of the question I'm not
sure if you guys got it obviously you
guys picked it I didn't fully understand
what the objective was of the magazines
was he referring to how do we make micro
digital context that actually gets
people to care about a magazine meaning
like buying a subscription to a magazine
actually I'm pretty curious while we're
here where is your magazine life right
now and ek0
nothing zero Dunc five percent what do
you what magazine would you consume
sweet and Swedish magazines that you
read that you'll look at look every so
that comes to your home and you'll do
that yes and it has 5% of you're kind of
like
we're all do you think is your gut to
point pumpka d-roc zero other Tyler like
what do you consume like photography
design magazines a little bit you'll
flip through a little bit yeah how about
compared like how about compared to
twenty four months ago even less dunk
compared to twenty four months ago even
less say same India no less less less
India what do you have Playgirl
cuz I like you so what do you you know
so The New Yorker yes um and you read
that yeah and it's not just collecting
like you you think you read as much New
Yorker today than you did twenty four
months ago thirty six months ago and cuz
there's a scenario where you like it
like weekend morning coffee kind of
thing or perfect so it got it
look I think you know that's obviously a
small focus group majus think it's a I
mean if you were talking and I don't
know Brannan effort so that's where I'm
gonna have to go if you're talking about
the notion of what kind of content can
we put out jabs in an ecosystem that is
going to get Millennials excited about
then going into the magazine world and
subscribing to a magazine I think that's
a lost cause I really do it and I think
the magazines that have anybody's
attention right now I bet you if we
could take these three wonderful
people's brains and put them here and
dissect how they cared about the
photographer magazine The New Yorker and
the Swedish magazines it had a lot more
to do what those brands did to them
10-15 years ago and that's the problem
they they thought things were cool
magazines when they were in junior high
they were around in the house The New
Yorker is an iconic thing like I I think
it's a very difficult proposition and as
digital and mobile devices have become
more maggin like magazine eyes aka
photos have become such a foundation of
the way we consume the internet versus
written words of a decade ago I think
you're you're fighting an uphill battle
my friend
yeah we'll just do hey Gary I'm Sam I'm
from Nigeria I'm living in Thurman says
he said I'm sorry my question for you is
we to stop the start of mobile
development agency brah was that too
hard for you bruh that's amazing I love
that hold D are you blank do you even
lift bro
so did he say am i too soft to start a
mobile uh I want to say I want to I want
to fight you is really what I want to do
but yeah I mean look I think um I think
that to answer in a straight way the
reason building a development shop in a
genre is not interesting to me is that I
would if I was to build a development
shop in a meaningful way right now I
would build a messenger development shop
way before I build a mobile app shop
brah because I don't care about you know
2016 you know
legacy software to me the reason I built
the company I built is that unlike a VCR
or a video game console or a cell phone
or virtual reality messaging is
tried-and-true the mechanism that
delivers it gets killed eventually right
so the guy caveman Rick who took a rock
and carved it into the cave he was
messaging and communicating right but
the platform of the day where the
eyeballs were were inside the cave and
the smoke signals and the written word
and a telephone and a television and a
movie theater and a cell phone and a VR
world and apps within a cell phone and
so bruh
the reason I didn't go with a mobile
development shop is it was just too
small and I needed to win the
communication game infrastructure that I
can deploy against any mechanism that
delivers the story brah
found it that's awesome by the way
thanks for the question Gary Vee what's
happening man my name is beau Misaki I'm
a real estate agent in a motivational
blogger and have a question for you
about self-awareness you've spoken a lot
about this topic um and how to gain
self-awareness you've also touched on
how meditation is a trend that's really
gonna take over and be in every
household in the near future so what are
your thoughts on how to gain
self-awareness through meditation
I myself gained a lot of self-awareness
and clarity on who I am and what my
actual goals are through meditation so
what are your thoughts on how meditation
can help you gain self-awareness thanks
bow thanks for the question I think the
answer is I believe I believe I believe
you would be no reason for you to make
this video and lie I believe that
there's a lot of people that are gain it
I'm a very very very strong advocate for
way more discovery by the human race
around understanding the brain and
mental health mental fitness meant
mental mental mental method I promise
you that when it's all said and done for
me people realize that that was the game
that I won that that's the gift that I
was given that that was where I had
all-time skills it's just we've grown up
in a world and I for the last 40 years
whether that was in the conversation
nope you know people can tell if you're
pretty or good at athletics
nobody rolled up I mean like yo bro your
brain is on point right like it wasn't
you know and one and I'd say that
because when I say brain I mean the
mental pillars of emotional intelligence
that are the foundation of everything
I've been talking about for last four
years you could tell me I'm good at
school memorizing something and
regurgitating that's not what we're
talking about it's having that centering
having that place that energy that
allows you to navigate through all
adversity not getting too high on your
highs and not getting too low in your
low it's balanced it's the
contradictions that make me me
I want awesomeness for everybody but I
want to punch all of you in the face too
because if you want to compete with me
you're going to lose and it's all that's
up sorry India and that's all that stuff
and so it's it's all of that
foundational stuff that we need
more four and if meditation through a
process is what unlocks people to be
happier to be more grateful to deploy
more empathy to do all the
tried-and-true cliche things that would
make the world awesome awesome then we
would be in a really really good spot
and I don't believe that there's Nirvana
and to be perfect but moving anything
just a little bit really works we've had
world wars like we've had you know
epidemics we've had you know enormous
atrocities we continue to do them in the
world today there's genocide and things
I mean what people are confused and so
yeah I'm all bow to bow T I don't even
know I said that but I was thinking
about Master P the other day I'm all
about all about people understanding
that mental health meditation all these
things have a lot of upside and that we
do not understand anything about the
brain currently just an enormous vast
opportunity for us over the next century
to learn more about this and and I'm and
I'm excited and grateful that my great
great great great grandchildren will
live in a world where that will be
understood far more in a substantial way
in the way that people died from disease
that we so easily navigate through today
all these unhappy people and all these
tragedies and all these negatives that
are completely completely coming from
the fact that the mental status of that
person isn't in the best place that
could be are going to be an amazing
challenge for our for for a race for our
world for who we are as humans and and
I'm really into it and I really Bank
that that is where so much of my
happiness comes from I'm actually quite
sad that I'm not going to be able to see
it where it's going to be a hundred
years from today unless somebody figures
out some technology and I'm into it I
bump to be a buck forty I will Yoda this
[ __ ] world up but uh and so that's
that
I would love to look like you oh well I
mean a punch line there is like if you
told me I could live to 840 and it would
be like Yoda or crane from Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles where I'm just a
brain in a machine but I know what's up
I'd be into that well I'd probably think
yoga only because he's still like a
complete thing and idrac badass cane of
like a india you know but like where
you're still there yeah you're still
around well because if I figured I'd
pass it on to you welcome I prefer you
live oh yes
question of the day cuz it's actually an
interesting question because I actually
think this last little rant is not for
everybody if you could control it if I
told you weird thing India's a genie
from the future can make anything happen
in the comments section and just go you
know if the you can justify it you can
do whatever you want but just the
numbers fine by me if you could control
it at what age do you want to die how
long do you want to live what number
Andy on the spot let's go quick let's go
one for dunk infinity is the only non
answer allowed 140 140 yeah other Tyler
150
[Music]
a hundred yeah you're so you're so
you're so that said that was I would
have bet the farm on it you're going to
be your counterculture like oh I don't
know it's right I don't know mines old I
think mine would be 888 you asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]